his theory he says is that no one is
smart enough to come up with 20 bad
ideas in a row
once a writer has processed their own
defining moments how do they begin to
apply that knowledge to the characters
that they create well when i think about
applying
the idea of defining moments to
characters
uh i think in terms of these categories
so
if i've got a character who
has a dream
i've already looked back at
my moment of watching ordinary people
and seeing this dream of somehow getting
my fingers into the clay of filmmaking
so i know about how at least one dream
was born
then i can come to my character and say
for this character what does it look
like when their dream was born now their
dream may be to be an astronaut
and so i would think about well
what is analogous
from my experience to their experience i
was watching a movie
an astronaut dream might have been born
as somebody was watching
a shuttle launch
or
the tragic loss of a shuttle
um
that immediately interests my writer's
brain because it's unexpected that you
would
see a catastrophic loss of a space
shuttle and say
that's what i want to do
but
i think that's actually often how it
works
i've described television writing
to aspiring writers and the atmosphere
in the writers room and how you have to
compete to get
your joke on the page and
how cutthroat that can be
and i think i've just talked to everyone
out of wanting to be a television writer
and then people will crowd to the front
and say that sounds fantastic that's
exactly what i want to do
so that tells me
that sometimes it's even
seeing
[Music]
a story that seems like it would drive
you away
that actually attracts the die hard um
dreamer
so i i bring that sort of general
experience from life i kind of mix it up
with what i've observed in myself
and i
i will often try to brainstorm
a bunch of different options
of what that defining moment might be
until i find one that both
feels
emotionally real
and also
makes an interesting story because i
might
have the character tell the story or we
may flash back to see that story
uh the writer bill marcilli
who wrote
the film deja vu
talks about
his discipline of brainstorming 20
options for
any creative choice
and his theory he says is that no one is
smart enough to come up with 20 bad
ideas in a row
so
one of your 20 ideas is bound to be
decent
so i've taken to calling that marcilli's
rule of 20.
it is a discipline
because often when we're coming up with
say a potential defining moment for a
character
we want to
just
jump at the first thing that occurs to
us
part of
becoming a mature writer is recognizing
that it's not supposed to be that easy
and so we want to stick with it and keep
coming up with options
so that we don't pick the first thing
that occurs to us which probably is the
first thing that is going to occur to
everyone else
we want to get to
something else further down the line
that's unexpected that we haven't seen
before
and if i'm drawing from my own
life experiences
that has a real chance of being fresh
because it's drawn from life
not from the movies
so that would be how i would go about
finding say one defining moment so a
dream is born
maybe in the course of the film this
dream is going to die
so then i would look at my own life and
also
lives of people around me that i know
well and say where have i seen
a dream die
and i can think for myself a defining
moment
um
where
dreams died
and
in my experience dreams die slowly
they die kicking and screaming we don't
want to admit
that thing that you dreamed is not going
to happen
and so i would draw on that and say how
do i how do i bring that
to this character
and i would keep doing that until i had
that handful of moments that
gives me an understanding of this
character that makes them
complex
and relatable
and interesting
and when i really i can feel myself
when a character starts to come alive in
this way
and i i know i want to spend time with
that character and i want to hear
the dialogue that they're going to say
and i want to see them get into
whatever trouble the story is getting
them into and i want to see them
struggle
to get out of that trouble to get to
their goal
and i also want to watch them
grow over the course of that story
either
for good or for ill they're going to
change
and they're going to change
in in these moments these pivot points
and so i just keep at it
until i feel like
i have
this full character it's it's an organic
messy
uh
process definitely not paint by the
numbers but
having
my own
history and an understanding of myself
to draw on
also having this sort of set of
characteristics of defining moments
helps me at least know where to look and
then i just
i try to keep looking and until i found
what i need to find
it's interesting because we're talking
about defining moments for various
characters and knowing them sometimes if
i've watched a biopic i feel as if
the filmmaker has tried to cram in so
many defining moments that it loses some
of the impact of them and i think it's
because there's so much to tell yeah but
then i've seen documentaries where they
also do the same and for some reason it
lands better i i don't know why that
would be
i don't know i do think that um
the best biopics tend to focus on a
single event i think of
spielberg's lincoln
and you know we know so much of abraham
lincoln's life and career
and
spielberg
and
tony kushner the screenwriter chose to
focus on
just a single vote
in the u.s house of representatives
about the amendment to the constitution
that outlawed slavery
and so out of everything you could look
at in lincoln's life and career
the film
focuses on a single event
and
i think we get
a bunch more
dramatic power
focused when when we do that
and it can be really tempting
if you're doing a biopic because so many
interesting things happened in
in many people's lives uh if we were
doing winston churchill there'd be so
many things to focus on but the
fantastic film darkest hour
focuses
very specifically on
the
couple of weeks
leading up to winston churchill's speech
to parliament
where he declares we're going to fight
on the beaches we're going to fight on
the landing field where he galvanizes
the british people to oppose
the nazis
those
that that is a dramatic move
to
to restrict yourself in that way
and uh at the risk of sounding
uh
disgustingly like a film professor i'll
go back to aristotle one more time
and
aristotle as long ago as that
said that the drama
should be about a single
event and i think that i think he's
right and i think that um
for reasons i don't understand
uh we are
we are geared toward a story of
a hero struggling against obstacles to
reach a goal there is a unity
to
drama
that
both focuses its power but also
helps to give it
meaning
because there's a
there's a configuration of events that
becomes meaningful
these choices and these actions led to
this outcome
so that's it gives us this sense of
completion that i think we
was one of the things that we long for
from our stories